Okay.
Hallo, guten Tag.
ATG ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Dienstabend der Arztfeute
und ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Wie heißen Sie?
Das ist gut.
Danke schön.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Natalia Kremer.
Natalia Kremer.
Können Sie bitte für mich Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist N-A-T.
N-A-T-L-I-A.
Und mein Familienname ist K-R-A-Umlaut-Ä.
M-E-R.
Kremer.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Kremer.
Bevor wir über Ihre Beschwerden spüren,
würde ich gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen über Sie stellen.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Kremer?
Ich bin 76 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau gebaut?
Am 4.6.46.
4.6.46.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Kremer?
1,68 Meter bin ich wohl noch.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 Kilo bringe ich wohl auf die Waage.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Was haben Sie?
Vorher haben Sie gemacht.
Ich habe lange beim Finanzamt gearbeitet.
Da macht man sich nicht nur Freunde.
Alles klar.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was hat Sie uns heute geführt?
Ich habe so unglaubliche Schmerzen auf der linken Seite im Rücken.
Das strahlt in den ganzen Rücken rein.
Das sind ganz unangenehme Schmerzen.
Vor zwei Tagen hat das angefangen.
Es ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Seit zwei Tagen haben Sie in Ihrer linken Seite von Rücken
unglaubliche Schmerzen.
Das ist eine sehr unangenehme Schmerz.
Vor zwei Tagen hat das angefangen.
Es ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Es ist unglaubliche Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in den ganzen Rücken hin.
Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Das ist ein zielender, stechender Schmerz.
Das ist ganz unangenehm.
Stecke der Schmerzen.
Wenn ich mich hinlege, dann geht es.
Dann kann ich das gerade aushalten.
Aber sobald ich mich bewege, tut das weh.
Wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe,
dann habe ich auch solche Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen.
Ich muss so oft laufen zurzeit.
Das ist ganz unangenehm.
Ich muss erst mal sagen, Sie sind eine tolle Patientin.
Sie antworten meine alle Fragen, bevor ich stelle.
Ich muss Ihnen erzählen, warum ich komme.
Ich habe solche Schmerzen, wissen Sie.
Das ist so unangenehm.
Das ist toll.
Ich würde gerne erst mal Schritt für Schritt gehen.
Ihre Schmerzen sind stechende Schmerzen.
Sie haben gesagt, das ist unerträglich und ganz schlimm.
Aber auf einer Stelle,
wie stark ist Ihre Schmerzen von 0 bis 10?
10 wäre unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Bei 7 sind Sie bestimmt.
Sie haben gerade die Schmerzen.
Sie haben gerade die tolle Schmerzen.
Wenn ich jetzt hier so sitze, geht es.
Wenn ich jetzt aufstehen müsste und wieder zur Toilette laufen,
dann wäre es wieder schlecht.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen etwas dagegen geben.
Aber ich muss erst mal Sie untersuchen.
Können Sie bis die Ende der Anamnese durchhalten?
Klar, ich habe jetzt schon 2 Tage.
Alles klar.
Sie haben insbesondere auch beim Wasserlassen Schmerzen.
Das brennt, wenn ich Wasser lassen muss.
Ich muss zur Zeit ganz oft gehen.
Sie gehen oft auf die Klo.
Dann kommt gar nicht viel.
Und es tut weh.
Welcher Farbe hat Ihre Wasserlassen, Ihre Urin?
Ich habe gerade die Schmerzen.
Ist das die Rötel?
Gut ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen dunkler.
Man sieht das ja nicht so in diesen modernen Toiletten.
Aber es scheint so, als ob das ein bisschen dunkler wäre.
Es ist ein dunkler.
Haben Sie eine komische Geruchbemerkung beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, das riecht schon nicht so gut zur Zeit.
Haben Sie gleichzeitig Übelkeit?
Nein, mir ist eigentlich es mir jetzt ein bisschen schlecht von den Schmerzen.
Ich fühle mich einfach total schlapp und schlecht.
Klar.
Seit zwei Tagen haben Sie diese Schmerzen.
Gleichzeitig haben Sie die dunkle Urin mit brennender Wasserlassen.
Okay.
Ich habe gerade die Schmerzen.
Ich habe die Urin mit brennender Wasserlassen.
Okay.
Ihre Schmerzen und Ihre Probleme beim Wasserlassen
sind dauerhaft, oder?
Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Das ist ja erst seit zwei Tagen.
Aber so, die Schmerzen sind jetzt schon andauernd.
Okay.
Haben Sie lieber Farbe?
Ja, wenn Sie so fragen, ich habe heute Nacht tüchtig geschwitzt.
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Aber gemessen.
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Haben Sie auch Schütterfrost zum Beispiel?
Ja, also, als ich dann auf der Toilette war, war mir so ein bisschen kalt.
Aber als ich dann wieder im Bett war, ging das.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit, Farmeier?
Also, zurzeit schmeckt es mir wirklich nicht so gut.
Normalerweise ist das ja nicht mein Problem.
Also, die 80 kg habe ich ja nicht von ungefähr.
Aber jetzt, diese letzten Tage, hat mir das Essen nicht gut geschmeckt.
Okay.
Wenn Sie sich in Deutschland haben, haben Sie es abgenommen?
Nein, das ist eigentlich so stabil.
Mein Gewicht, das habe ich schon lange.
Da wäre ich nicht wie nix von los.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie nachts weiß haben.
Es ist nur seit zwei Tagen oder?
Das war jetzt nur, ja, seit es mir so schlecht geht, habe ich das sonst.
Normalerweise nicht.
Wie ist Ihre Schlafen?
Können Sie durchschlafen?
Normalerweise schlafe ich ganz gut.
Aber jetzt renne ich halt auch nachts.
Irgendwann zwischendurch auf die Toilette.
Okay.
Hat im Not alle Probleme beim Ihre Herz?
Das ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, eigentlich.
Ich meine, ich habe ja so ein bisschen Bluthochdruck oder so, aber
jetzt akut, dass das Herz irgendwie ärger macht, habe ich nicht das Gefühl.
Okay, alles klar.
Dann gehen wir mit Ihrer Vorgeschichte.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie unter den Hochblutdruck leiden,
aber bitte gerne erst mal so Fragen zu.
Welche Krankheiten haben Sie in Ihrem Vorgeschichte?
Leiden Sie unter chronische Krankheiten?
Ich meine, super Krankheiten.
Ich habe ein Diabetes seit 20 Jahren, ja?
So ein Altersdiabetes.
Da muss ich halt mal mit Formin regelmäßig nehmen.
Aber sonst merke ich da eigentlich nicht viel davon.
Das wird auch immer mal wieder beim Hausarzt kontrolliert.
Es ist nur mit Formin, oder?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihre Blutzügebild so seit?
Ihre Hausarzt hat Ihnen etwas gesagt?
Ist das ganz normal, oder?
Im Augenblick scheint das so gut im Griff zu sein mit dem Metformin.
Okay.
Und Hochblutdruck?
Dann nehme ich Rami-Pril.
Und wissen Sie, für diese Medikamentewürste dosen nehmen Sie einen.
Bei Rami-Pril, das ist Rami-Pril 5.
Und dann nehme ich morgens eine.
Und von dem Metformin nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Und ich meine, das ist eine Tausende.
Tausende?
Mhm.
Okay.
Alles klar.
In Ihrem Vorgeschichte haben Sie Operationen oder Eingriffe,
so zum Beispiel, wie den Blindam steht noch oder schon weg?
Den Blindam habe ich noch.
Nee, eigentlich bin ich noch ganz komplett.
Ich habe noch alles, ist noch nicht, ist noch nicht operiert worden.
Okay.
Und Unfälle zum Beispiel?
Nee, zum Glück bin ich noch bis zu Heilungsleben gekommen.
Ja.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Und außer mit Formin und Rami-Pril,
nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich habe noch ein bisschen Probleme,
so mit der Luft, dann nehme ich Spiriva.
Spiriva.
Haben Sie gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder Lebensmittel,
Allergie oder Punktverträglichkeit?
Das habe ich bisher noch nicht festgestellt.
Nee, bisher bin ich immer, habe ich nie Schwierigkeiten gehabt.
Ich kann alles essen und kann auch alle Tabletten vertragen.
Und wie ist Ihre Impfstatus?
Zum Beispiel gegen die Corona.
Ja, natürlich bin ich gegen Corona, 3-mal.
Ja, klar.
Und mit den anderen Impfungen?
Ja, mein Haushalt ist da eigentlich auch ganz konsequent.
Ich habe also alle Impfungen, die jetzt so empfohlen werden.
Ja, auch hier gegen Gürtelrose zum Beispiel,
hat mein Hausarzt mich damals impfen lassen.
Alles klar.
Und wann war Ihre letzte Durchblutung,
Ihre Pause?
Oh, das ist schon so lange her.
Ich bin auch schon so alt.
Weiß ich nicht mehr, wie lange das her.
Das war so mit 50, also 25 Jahre her.
Okay.
Leben Sie allein oder mit Ihrem Partner,
mit Ihrem Ehemann?
Ich bin verwitelt schon lange.
Ich lebe alleine.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die Kinder, aber die sind natürlich alle groß
und sind weit weg.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die Kinder sind alle gesund, ja.
Und haben Sie geschwisten?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder und eine Schwester.
Und sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ich habe einen Bruder.
Ja, die sind genauso alt wie ich.
Die sind natürlich auch nicht gesund.
Der eine hat Diabetes und die Schwester,
die hat auch das weiß ich hohen Blutdruck.
Und Ihre Eltern, so, wissen Sie,
so, oder muss ich ja so sagen,
so lebt Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, die leben natürlich nicht mehr.
Die müssen ja fast 100 sein.
Es können sein, so, ich habe noch immer Patienten
in den Jahren, in Deutschland ist das ganz normal, glaube ich.
Ganz normal?
Nein, meine Eltern sind schon länger tot.
Und mein Vater, der hat sich tatsächlich auch
so ein altes Diabetes und ja,
aber der ist trotzdem alt geworden.
Meine Mutter, die hatte ihn herzinfacht.
Die waren aber beide hoch in den 80ern,
als sie gestorben sind.
Okay, alles klar.
Wir kommen bald am Ende, ich muss ein paar andere Fragen stellen.
So, warum Sie Frau Kremer?
Ja, so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag rauche ich wohl, ja.
Seit wann?
Ach, schon ewig.
Bestimmt 50 Jahre.
50 Jahre.
Früher mal ein bisschen mehr, jetzt ein bisschen weniger.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, mal so ein Glas Rotwein, das gönne ich mir schon, ja.
Ja, wie viel Glas ist zum Beispiel pro Woche?
In der Woche.
Auch vielleicht so drei, vier, je nachdem, wie ich Lust habe.
Und nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage nicht böse,
so ich stelle diese Frage meiner alle Patenten und Patientinnen.
Ist Ihnen mit den Drogen irgendwann in Ihrem Leben Kontakt bekannt?
Ich, Drogen?
Nein, also lebendig.
Nein, damit habe ich nix mit dem Sinn.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Haustiere? Nein, nicht mehr.
Früher hatte ich mal einen Hund, aber ja, jetzt habe ich da nichts mehr.
Okay, und meine restliche Frage wäre,
waren Sie im Ausland seit so im letzten sechs Monaten?
In den letzten sechs Monaten?
Nein, war ich nie im Ausland.
Okay.
Man konnte ja so schlecht weg, wegen Corona war ja alles zu.
Jetzt bin ich froh, wenn ich klarkomme.
Okay, alles klar.
Ich bin durch mit meiner Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Sie haben so viel gefragt und ich habe so viel erzählt.
Es möchte ich eigentlich nur noch wissen,
wie ich meine Schmerzen los werde, was man dagegen tun kann.
Ich kann das total verstehen.
Meine Plan ist gerade,
dass ich erst mal Ihnen körperlich untersuchen sollte.
Und danach möchte ich von Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und dann, weil Sie mit den Wasserlassen so Schmerzen haben,
so würde ich gerne von Ihnen die Urinprobe so entnehmen.
Ah ja, mhm.
Und danach gehen wir durch mit den Utraschar
und dann spüre ich mit meinen Oberarzen.
Und dann komme ich Ihnen mit einer guten Lösung und Diagnose.
Das ist gut, ja, wunderbar.
Aber wenn Sie möchten, nach der Untersuchung,
kann ich Ihnen gerne eine Schmerzmittel verschreiben und geben.
Und dann können Sie ein bisschen Ihre Rufe haben.
Das ist ja klar, das wird nicht gut gebrauchen können, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Und dann ganz kurz momentan nach der Untersuchung,
gebe ich Ihnen die Kommentare.
Gut, alles klar.
Ich möchte etwas fragen.
Ja.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein, hatte ich noch nie.
Können Sie mir beschreiben, wie die Beschwerden aufgetreten sind?
Sind Sie eher langsam oder plöselig begonnen?
Mh.
Sie haben langsam angefangen, sind schlimmer geworden.
Ja, leiden Sie öfter an Blasenentzündung.
Ja, früher habe ich das häufiger mal gehabt,
aber in letzter Zeit eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen,
die aufgrund Ihrer Beschwerden?
Ja, ich habe das natürlich versucht.
Ibuprofen habe ich mal genommen,
damit die Schmerzen besser werden.
Aber das hat nicht so richtig geholfen.
Wie oft und wie stark Ibuprofen?
Ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Dosierung ist,
aber ich habe zwei Mal am Tag,
also einmal morgens, einmal abends,
aber das hat alles nicht so richtig geholfen.
Die Schmerzen sind jetzt doch immer noch wieder sehr doll.
Vielen Dank.
Noch etwas fragen, Kollegen?
Denke, keine.
Selma.
Würden Sie schon?
Würden Sie schon loslegen?
Ja.
Brauchen Sie doch einen Moment.
Nein, für mich ist ganz okay.
Wir können gerne sofort gehen.
Je schneller daran, je schneller davon.
Alles klar.
In meiner Prüfung müssen wir so.
Ich habe keine Zwischendurch.
Sie haben keine Zeit.
Okay.
In meiner Prüfung machen wir das im Rostock,
im Mecklenburg-Pfopommern.
Okay.
Im Mecklenburg-Pfopommern machen wir als Patentgespächt.
Wir haben eine kleine Laborergebnisse.
Dann haben wir fünf Minuten Zeit,
dass wir diese Ergebnisse lesen können.
Dann müssen wir sofort die Art ausgefügt.
Dann geht es los.
Am Ende schreiben wir eine Entlassung griffen.
Ah ja.
Gut, dann legen wir los.
Okay.
Guten Tag, meine Oberärztin.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patentin aufgenommen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich,
dass wir darüber sprechen können?
Ja, erzählen Sie.
Ich habe eine neue Patentin aufgenommen.
Okay.
Natalie Crema,
76-jährige Patentin,
die übergewicht ist und berätet.
Sie stellte sich
wegen der seit zwei Tagen bestehenden
linke-seitige Rückenschmerzen.
Auf einer Skala
liegt die Schmerzen bei 7.
Und bei einer Hinlegen
reduziert sich die Schmerzen.
Und bei Bewegung
verschlechtert sich die Schmerzen.
Und gleichzeitig
haben Sie
die Probleme und die Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen.
Und brennen die Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen.
Sie berichtet,
dass Urin dunkler geworden sei
und schlechter gerucht hat.
Durchwelleübelkeit
und die Schmerzen
haben sich
in der Skala
durchwelleübelkeit
von der Patentin
verneint.
Und
Bezimptome
sind auch ja von der Patentin verneint.
Nur Fieber
ist hier aufgefallen,
aber hat sie das nicht gemessen.
Sie hat nur
berichtet,
dass er manchmal
kalt ist.
Sie hat für die Schwere
nur Ibuprofen 2x pro Tag
eingenommen.
Sie erinnert sich nicht daran,
was die Dorsis dafür war.
Sie leidet unter Diabetes meleutus 2
und Hypertension.
Und für Diabetes meleutus
nimmt sie mit Formin 2x pro Tag
1000mg.
Und für Hypertension
nimmt sie Rameprel 5mg
einmal pro Tag ein.
Opi-Geschichte
oder Unfallgeschichte, Allergien
ist
unaufwillig, keine Allergien ist ihr bekannt.
Familienanamnese
ist auch unaufwillig.
Reiseanamnese ist unaufwillig.
Sie raucht
seit 30
Paket
ja.
Sie trinken Alkohol 2-3
gelöse pro Woche.
Das wäre
unsere Patentin.
Was haben Sie für eine
Diabetes-Jagdose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose wäre
Globaleonephitis.
Sie klagt über
Flankenschmerzen.
Bei der Untersuchung kann ich das besser verstehen.
Aber bisher
habe ich so verstanden.
Sie hatte Flankenschmerzen und gleichzeitig
begleitet die Symptome
mit Wasser lassen.
Es wäre meine Verdachtdiagnose
erst mal Globaleonephitis.
Sie leidet auch ja
eine Diabetes-Jagdose.
In dieser Form
kann es auch sein,
dass sie
dazu neigen,
die Handweginfektion
haben.
Unsere Patentin ist schon alt.
Es ist auch möglich,
dass sie das vorher nicht bemerkt hatte.
Dass
öfter mal diese Infektion
gehabt hatte.
Aber so wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr übersehen kann. Was geht mit Differenzialdiagnostisch noch in Frage?
Es kann auch hier sein, so nephrotiliert jasis, so nierensteine kann sein,
handbelasen intinuen kann sein, handbelasen katinormen sein,
in diesem Fall die Blasen-Katinormen kann auch Probleme bei die Wasser lassen führen.
Und in diesem Fall es kann auch Staunenprobleme bei den Nieren.
Ah, das stimmt. Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin jetzt?
Ich würde gerne erstmal, wie ich gesagt habe, Blut abnehmen,
dann kann ich ja Blut zur Katiniveo und Diabetes mehr tiefer verstehen.
Und dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall die Turin abnehmen.
Auf jeden Fall, die sind alle nach der köpferlichen Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Flanke schmerzen. Ich würde gerne gucken, ob Sie die Flanke schmerzen haben
oder die schmerzen liegen an die Böbelsäule oder so, weil unsere Patentin nicht alt ist.
Es kann auch aus der Perosis sein, Böbelsäule-Probleme sein und so weiter.
Und in diesem Fall würde ich gerne diese Beide-Symptome gleichzeitig urteilen.
Und bei der Urin-Probe würde ich gerne gucken, ob es eine Leukosythbeide-Urin gibt
oder eine Tweet gibt.
So Entzündungsparameter würde ich gerne gucken.
Oder so Erdprosythes gibt und so weiter.
Dann, meine nächste Schritt wäre Ultraschall.
Unter den Ultraschall kann ich auch gucken, ob es Nierensteine gibt
bei die Uretta oder Ureta.
Und wenn ich das nicht sehen kann, würde ich gerne mit den Röntgenaufnahmen weitergehen.
Aber am Ende wäre es die letzte diagnostische Methode, so ist das Kopie.
Ah ja, genau.
Und dann kann ich gucken, ob es in der Hamblase, in die Ureta,
ob es etwas gibt, ob es eine Katzinome ist oder nicht.
So in diesem Fall, in der Familienanahmenase gibt es nicht,
aber trotzdem vorsichtig besser als nach sich.
Gut.
Und wenn sich das jetzt bestätigt, ja, also wenn sich die Nefritis bestätigt,
was würden Sie dann therapeutisch machen?
Wie bitte, was habe ich bestätigt?
Wenn die Nefritis, was Sie gesagt haben, sich bestätigt,
was würden Sie dann therapeutisch machen?
Wenn es Nefritis ist, ok, so ich würde gerne das Apollosporin geben.
Ja, und was machen Sie noch?
Ich empfehle Sie, dass Sie genug trinken sollte,
Betruche und auf jeden Fall die Anagätikung.
Und in diesem Fall so.
Gut.
Und nehmen Sie die Patienten stationär auf?
Es gibt daraufhin, wie ist die Situation bei ihr?
Normalerweise kann man die Nefritis so ambulant,
so ambulante Arche folgen.
Aber in diesem Fall, dass unser Patientin ziemlich alt ist
und das würde ich gerne sie stationär aufnehmen,
weil in diesem Fall mit die Diabetes meleutus und diese Probleme,
sie kann sofort und einfach in diesem Bild die Exikose gehen kann.
Ich würde gerne so erstmal stationär aufnehmen.
Ja, und das heißt, Sie würden auch wahrscheinlich relativ kurz
nach stationärer Aufnahme was machen,
damit Sie ordentlich wässern können?
Wie viele Parameter würde ich gerne gucken?
Ne, ich meine es gerade etwas anderes.
Was meinen Sie?
Damit Sie Antibiosik gut geben können
oder damit Sie gut bewässern können?
Was machen Sie da?
Ich würde gerne die so näheren Funktionen schrücken.
Ne, ich meine Sie, dass Sie eine Infusion legen.
Ja, genau.
Wenn Sie sich so stationär haben, legen Sie ja auch eine Infusion.
Eine Branöle und eine Infusion.
Dann legen Sie Zugang und hängen die Infusion dran
und dann können Sie das Antibiotikum systemisch geben.
Dann gehen wir.
Gut, ja, ich würde mal sagen in Rekordgeschwindigkeit, oder?
Haben Sie diese Patienten hier abgearbeitet?
Gut.
Ich habe gerade eine Illegiariatrie,
so in der letzten Woche hatte ich eine Patentin so
und deswegen sage ich doch so, es kann sein.
Ich hatte diese Woche zwei Patienten,
ein von denen war 94 und die anderen war 97.
Deswegen denke ich, dass es üblich in Deutschland,
dass man so lange leben kann.
Man 100 ist jetzt.
Ja, das ist meine Meinung.
Ich fühle mich auch gekommen, wenn ich das frage,
ob ihre Eltern leben oder nicht.
Aber dann denke ich, wenn man, zum Beispiel,
als 19 Jahre alt, zum Beispiel,
im Alter 19 Jahre, so Mutter geworfen ist.
Kinder bekommen nach Jahr, da kann das sein.
Das kann sein, weil ich habe,
weil ich gesagt habe, in diesem Fall ist es so,
für diese Patentin 95, ich hatte Patentin, die 97 Jahre alt war.
Wow, ja.
Aber die 75, die 76-Jährige, jetzt war ihnen auch nicht fremd.
Ja, und die hat so viel geredet.
Ich habe dann schon weniger gesagt,
weil sie mich ermahnt haben.
Nein, es war richtig toll.
Wie gesagt, ich wollte fragen,
können Sie für mich beschreiben?
Bevor ich frage, Sie haben schon gesagt, es ist stegende Schmerzen.
Die hat ja ein bisschen gejammert.
Man muss ja ein bisschen sagen, ah, warum komme ich denn?
Das tut so weh.
Deswegen wollte ich ein bisschen beruhigen.
Ich finde diese Methode immer so.
Ich stelle dir die Fragen.
Nein, aber in diesem Fall sollte man ein bisschen schamant sein.